aujourd'hui les enfants croule sous les
cadeaux de noël
autrefois c'était très différent
l'écrivain jean giono en garde un
souvenir ému
j'avais quelques petits barons glace et
quelques petites papillotes et c'était à
noël magnifique magnifique peut-être est
bien plus simple aussi jusqu'à la fin
des années 40 dans les familles modestes
il n'y avait pas forcément de sapins et
les cadeaux étaient déposées devant la
cheminée on pourra rêver aux aventures
de la nuit magique quand les souliers
abandonnés à eux-mêmes attendent seul le
père noël et autrefois comme aujourd'hui
même excitation pour des enfants de vous
avant tout le monde pour découvrir leurs
cadeaux 5h30 on chez les verts on allait
vers à la gayonne au banc pour les plus
grands les petits jets l'alien une barre
de chocolat l'opéra la bdta offrir des
oranges c'était une façon de célébrer le
solstice d'hiver et d'ensoleiller
symboliquement la journée la plus courte
de l'année
c'est encore deux fruits du pays chauds
le fruit qui est de la couleur du soleil
et qui représentait encore cette notion
de fête de lumière comment est on passé
d'une orange et de quelques pièces de
monnaie à la frénésie des cadeaux que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui
la sociologue marty perron nous
l'expliquent peu à peu ses étrennes ont
été offertes le 24 décembre et les les
magasins ont transformé ces étrennes en
cadeau de noël mais s'il voulait c'est
vraiment une invention commercial à ce
moment là
en 2018 le budget moyen des foyers
français pour leurs cadeaux de noël et
de 342 euros
il a baissé de 12% par rapport à 2012
soit 45 euros de moins baisse du pouvoir
d'achat ou changement de comportement
des consommateurs
l'étude ne le précise pas
[Musique]